E isso muda radicalmente a velocidade na
criação de projetos e também na
consistência. Uma das principais dores
que as pessoas têm com o IA é a
consistência que a gente consegue com
ela. Eu só dei esse prompt aqui e ele
criou um blog como se fosse com o estilo
downtropic. Qual o prompt que eu dei? É
esse aqui, ó. Crie uma linage com sobre
novidades de A seguindo este layout. Só
[música] isso eu escrevi. Meu promp foi
uma frase. Isso aqui é algo
principalmente para você conseguir
destravar. Fala lendários e lendárias,
estamos ao vivo aqui para mostrar para
vocês. Bom, já vou mostrar minha tela
aqui, porque isso aqui que vocês vão ver
hoje tá maravilhoso.
Eu criei aqui uma galeria
ah de design system para vocês,
design.md, né, para vocês poderem
utilizar em qualquer projeto, como vocês
estão vendo aqui. E eu vou mostrar como
vocês podem extrair design.md MD de
qualquer site para servir como
inspiração para criação e como utilizar
basicamente isso aqui. Ah, então hoje
essa live aqui ela vai ser uma
continuidade, digamos assim, da live
anterior, onde eu já falei um pouquinho
sobre o design. Se você não assistiu,
recomendo que você dê uma conferida lá,
mas também não se preocupa que eu vou
cobrir tudo que seja importante sobre
esse assunto aqui nessa live. Então,
vou falar um pouquinho sobre o
design.md, vou falar um pouquinho também
sobre como utilizar isso, né? Como
conseguir fazer as extrações de qualquer
design.md de um site. Isso pode servir
de referência para poder construir
construir qualquer coisa, basicamente.
Depois
também eh quero mostrar para vocês aqui
como você pode, utilizar isso, né?
Depois que a gente faz esse processo
aqui, depois que a gente já tem ah um
design.md, como é que a gente pode
extrair o nosso, como é que a gente pode
utilizar isso na criação ah de qualquer
projeto depois? E isso muda radicalmente
a velocidade na criação de projetos e
também na consistência. Uma das
principais dores que as pessoas têm com
o IA é a consistência que a gente
consegue com ela. Por quê? Porque ela
tende, ela é probabilística, ela ela ela
tende a sempre fazer alterações e
normalmente alterações naquilo que a
gente nem deseja muito, né? Muitos de
vocês devem ter testado já, seja um LB,
seja um Bolt, seja no próprio cloud code
de você fazer alterações e pedir
alterações simples, né, num botão
específico e
acabar aí modificando todo o resto.
Existem formas da gente proteger isso
neste cresce guard rail e o design. MD
do Google foi testado no stick, eu nunca
lembro como falar isso aqui. Ah, stick.
Se alguém souber aí, escreve para mim
nos comentários. Mas esse stick do
Google,
para quem não usou ainda, ele é muito
bom para fazer
para você jogar referências aqui e ele
começar a construir
variações das referências.
Ah, como é que eu gosto de fazer, né, a
estruturação quando vou fazer um novo
design, tá?
Toda vez que eu vou fazer um novo
design,
eu gosto de pegar e ter referências, né,
para começar de algum lugar, de algum
ponto. Como é que eu faço essas
referências? Eu gosto, tem existem
trocentos sites, né? Existem muitos
sites que tem templates, modelos e por
aí vai. Ahã.
Eu gosto de usar o Pinterest. Ele é mais
simples nesse sentido,
porque ele não necessariamente é um site
de design como Beh,
ah, ou como outros, né? Tem o Ben, tem
vários aí, mas eu gosto de manter as
coisas simples, né, de uma forma que
objetiva. Então, eu prefiro, ao invés de
pegar vários e vários sites de
referência, eu prefiro ter apenas um.
Então, qual que é o site de referência
que eu utilizo? Eu utilizo como
referência o Pinterest mesmo. Então,
quando eu vou criar um design, a
primeira coisa que eu faço é pegar
referências daqui e eu salvo de uma
pastinha. Essa pasta eu baixo ela ou nox
eu tenho ela, ele tá integrado com o
beren, ele baixa as as páginas do BR. E
daí o que que você faz com isso? falam.
Ah, eu vou para
aqui o skit para fazer às vezes
mudanças, né? Eu jogo aqui alguma alguma
página e ele vai alterando. Por exemplo,
que que é legal daqui, tá? E isso tá vem
muito antes do Cloud Design, né? Eh, se
tem uma coisa que eu posso falar bem do
Google,
é do AI Studio. E o AI Studio é de graça
e é muito bom para criar design, melhor
nos meus testes do que inclusive o Cloud
Design.
Ah, e o que por que que eu tô contando,
falando para vocês, né, do processo?
Porque
como é que eu descobri, né? Porque eu
uso design.md já faz
um tempinho já. Acho já faz uns dois
meses, três meses. Como é que tu usa
isso há tanto tempo? Se eles lançaram
isso faz, né? Faz aqui uma duas semanas
que eles botaram no ar, talvez menos.
Como é que tu utiliza isso há tanto
tempo se eles botaram no ar há duas
semanas? Porque tem um cara que se chama
Plío, que fica hackeando essas e fica eh
extraindo, né? E o Plío, ele tinha
vazado já o código deles e eu já tinha
entrado aqui, né? Como eu gosto sempre
de mexer nas configurações, eu entrei
aqui, vim fim mexendo nas alterações,
cliquei aqui, eu vim clicando, daí eu vi
que tinha design system aqui, daí eu vi
que dava para criar um novo, importar.
Daí eu vi isso aqui, ó,
importdesign.md.
Eu, ui, dá para importar design.md. Daí
eu vim aqui, mexi nas, ele eu vi que ele
tinha criado um template, ele tinha
criado um prompt, né, um system prompt
aqui e eu peguei esse system prompt e
comecei a fazer a abstração de system
prompt. Então eu já tô fazendo,
trabalhando com o design.md já faz
alguns meses, o que me deu no para
melhorar algumas coisas. Por quê? Porque
o design.m que eles publicaram aqui, o
Google publicou, ele é um design.
Como é que eu posso dizer? bem conciso,
bem conservador, tá? Ah, então ele é bem
conservador. Isso quer dizer o quê? Isso
quer dizer que ele não abrange todos os
componentes necessários para que a gente
consiga ter um design system ah que seja
mais fiel. Então é isso, de forma bem
resumida, assim, sabe? Ele é bem legal.
Tanto que eu uso ele como referência,
esse aqui, mas até porque eu acredito
que por que eu uso ele como referência?
Porque toda empresa que lança algo
antes das outras acaba criando esse
padrão que acaba se tornando universal.
Vamos lá. Skills veio da Antropic e
agora é universal. todas esses agentes.
Tanto que aqui, ó, o
Google Gemenai, ele usa ponto agents
high skills.
Então, tem aqui o agents skill aqui, ó,
para fazer isso aqui. Ah,
o foi a antrop que lançou o MCP. Todo
mundo começou a lançar, usar o MCP.
Então é uma boa prática você pegar o que
uma grande empresa fez como referência
de tokenização, de estruturação, para
que você tenha algo que seja mais
fidedigno e fiel ao que for lançado
posterior. Mas aqui a gente tá falando
de algo que não tá nem na versão um, tá
na versão 0.1. Então
eu humildemente
fiz melhorias aqui. Porque eu tô
dizendo, né, humidemente? Porque pode
ser que altere alguma coisa, etc. até
que eles consigam fazer algo melhor. Mas
por enquanto, ã, o que eu criei, ele tem
ele tá mais completo, né? Porque tem
componentes, elementos que permitem que
a IA se comporte criando designs mais
complexos do que esse aqui que eles
lançaram faz.
Então, beleza. E o que que é isso, Alan?
Esse design.md, o design. MD é como se
fosse um prompt, mas não é um prompt. Eu
vou mostrar para vocês por porque ele
ele é um system prompt. Como assim?
Olha,
um system prompt ele é um prompt que
deve ser carregado toda vez que a IA faz
uma interação. Então, diferente de um
prompt que você vai lá e dá uma vez, né?
O prompt você vai lá e dá uma vez. O
system prompt ele é sempre carregado nas
sessões.
Uma vez que você tem o design. MD, você
pode colocar ele como, por exemplo, o no
Lovble, você pode colocar ele como um
system prompt para ficar sempre
carregando.
Ah, no
Stick também, no EAI Studio também, ou
seja, qualquer lugar que você quiser,
você pode colocar esse ponto MD. Ele vai
estar sempre carregando,
ele vai estar sempre otimizado a daí a
criar todos os designs daquela forma.
E daí você começa a ter uma consistência
muito grande. Vou dar um exemplo por
aqui, ó. Eu queria criar um design de
um uma plataforma de educação infantil.
Você pode ver que existe uma
consistência que foi isso aqui eu fiz em
dezembro.
Dezembro, janeiro, fiz em janeiro. Pode
ver que tem uma consistência aqui, ó.
Essa consistência ela se dá por quê? Por
conta do design system, que é o quê? que
agora é o o design, o design system, não
é o design system, mas é o o o
system prompt, né? O design system como
um system prompt. E agora tem como a
gente adicionar, inclusive aqui, ó,
adicionar um design system com
design.md. Você pode adicionar ele aqui,
né? Ó, clico aqui em novo, create new,
importdesign.md.
Então você importa já o design. MD dessa
forma você tem, tá vendo a consistência
entre todas as páginas. Pode ver aqui,
ó, todas as partes existem uma
consistência visual. Posso até trocar as
cores de um menu em uma e outra, né? Mas
existe uma consistência visual entre
todas as páginas. Então é isso que ele
vai permitir que vocês façam, tá legal?
Alon. E como é que eu faço isso? Eu vou
trazer para vocês algumas ideias aqui do
meu processo, como eu faço. E para quem
ficar comigo até o final da live, eu vou
dar um presententão, que é o quê? Eu vou
entregar a skill que cria isso aqui para
mim, a skill que entra em qualquer site
e consegue extrair aqui, ó, o design.md
de qualquer site. Então, ela vai lá, ela
entra e consegue fazer a extração de
qualquer aqui. Eu tenho todos os sites,
né? Ã, vários sites. Todos os sites que
eu que eu fiz, eu já coloquei aqui para
vocês também poderem navegar e
conseguirem [limpando a garganta] pegar.
Então, se você quiser criar, por
exemplo, um site inspirado na, sei lá,
no Itaú, tá aqui, eu quero criar um site
inspirado na Tropic, tá aqui. Inclusive,
para você ver o quão isso aqui é
poderoso, eu criei até uma demonstração
aqui usando lovball mesmo.
Ah, tu usa loveball, eu uso
principalmente close design. De vez em
quando eu uso lovable só para subir alo
que eu criei com close design pro meu
time poder editar. Mas eu quis fazer
aqui um teste com o Lovbow, porque ele é
ele é uma coisa que tende a não
performar muito bem.
Ã, onde eu só dei um prompt aqui, ó. Eu
só dei esse prompt aqui e ele criou um
blog como se fosse com o estilo
downtropic. Qual o prompt que eu dei?
Esse aqui, ó. Crie uma lineage com sobre
novidades de A seguindo este layout. Só
isso eu escrevi. Eu es meu promp foi uma
frase, tá? Ah, mas como é que ele
conseguiu ficar nesse sentido, né? dessa
forma aqui. Tá todo bonitinho, tá com se
vocês abrir aqui o site da da Antropic,
deixa eu ver que o site,
ainda mais eu abri o blog deles por aí,
você vai ver que tem uma semelhança,
ó, os em todo formato. Deixa eu ver aqui
o blog deles, news.
E aqui, ó, formatinho ali das coisinhas
aqui, a tipografia, espaçamentos,
background, o footer preto. Eu fiz um
mais evoluído ainda também que eu vou
mostrar para vocês, que é esse aqui, ó.
Ah, deixa eu lembrar onde é que ele tá,
ó. Esse aqui é o Dropic. Ele também
ficou aqui, ó, fundo preto, etc. Vou
mostrar para vocês o outro que eu fiz
também ali, que é
uma extensão, né? Um deles é esse aqui,
ó. Red Pine,
onde daí tem toda a tipografia, tem
todos os elementos, tem tudo aqui.
E o que que por que que que por que que
ficou tão bom assim? Por, né, de uma com
um apenas um prompt por causa do design.
MD e eu posso fazer mais do que isso,
né? Eu posso abrir aqui, venho em
configurações,
venho aqui em projeto settings e coloco
aqui como memória, né? Agora eles
mudaram o local aqui. Deixa eu ver aqui.
Files.
Eu posso pedir para ele deixar isso
aqui, ó. Deixa esse esse
deixe o design
pbd que eu mandei aqui como informação
do seu conhecimento
para carregar a cada prompt que eu der.
Mas tem um lugarzinho aqui para botar,
mas como eu não mexo muito com lbow, eu
não, eles [limpando a garganta]
trocaram, eu não lembro onde é que é a
knowledge. Aqui, ó.
Aqui, ó. Coloque aqui o system prompt
agora, né? Que que você vai fazer daí?
Você vai pegar esse cara aqui, tá aqui,
ó. Copiar design.
E já vir aqui. É isso aqui. Copi design.
Venho aqui e colo. Pronto. Acho que mais
de 10.000. Tirou alguns, vou deixar ele
adaptad. Eu tinha um adaptado pro
para esse cara aqui.
Essa parte final vou tirar aqui para
É bem limitado
o número, né? Aqui foi. Vou deixar um
pronto para esse e salvo. A mesma coisa
em outros lugares. Então no momento
agora ele vai ter sempre as referências
aqui para poder utilizar.
O que que isso vai permitir agora? Que
você tenha essa consistência em todas as
páginas. Agora, como é, Alon, eu consigo
extrair isso? Eu criei uma skill que faz
isso com muita economia de token. Por
quê? Porque se você deixar LM rodando
para fazer toda essa análise, você vai
gastar
bastante token. Mas eu criei vários
scripts aqui, fiquei, eu tô quatro dias
criando isso aqui. É algo que vai estar
disponível pros meus alunos do IX
Enterprise e do Iox Advanced. Ã,
mas eu vou, para você que tiver aqui
nessa labal, eu vou entregar, eu vou
mandar uma página para você ali, você
coloca o seu e-mail e baixa essa skill.
Ah, como é que funciona essa skill? Ela
é bem simples de utilizar.
Deixa eu mostrar aqui.
Você vai tá,
né? Eu vou entrar aqui. Você vai est no
Ela, ela é uma skill, então ela funciona
com Cloud, com Codex, com Gemi. Ela
funciona com qualquer um. E você não
precisa estar com iOS instalado. Eu
deixei ela de uma forma que qualquer
pessoa pode utilizar. Ela se chama
design.md.
Você vai escrever design.md. Você vai
pegar um site, vamos pegar alguns Bens.
Bir, pegar o Ben, por exemplo, colo
aqui, dou enter e ele vai fazer todo o
processo aqui de extração desse design.
MD do beren.
Que que ele vai gerar aqui? Deixa eu
mostrar para vocês. Ele vai gerar um
arquivo
que você vai poder utilizar daí para
fazer esse processo.
Aqui são os que foram extraídos, ó. E eu
vou abrir um aqui para vocês. Abrir o da
própria Antropicendária.
Aqui
tem o design. aqui e tem aqui, ó,
preview. Então ele cria esse aqui. Ah,
aqui você vai ter, né, ele vai extrair
todas as cores, vai extrair os
elementos,
ó, vai inserir tudo para vocês e você
vai poder utilizar. Aí aqui tá o
design.md que ele vai extrair. Você
consegue utilizar ele. Ele já tem uma
versão aqui, ó. Inclusive para você
baixar aqui, ó, copy design, copiar o
promptá, mas se você já é desenvolvedor
ou trabalha com isso, você pode copiar
também só as configurações de Tailwin,
só o o CSS, só o estilo e tudo mais.
Ah,
e daí, beleza, daí você vai, e
lembrando, né, isso aqui é algo
principalmente para você conseguir
destravar. Por quê?
Porque você não quer ter, né, um site
que é igual da Antropic. Você quer pode
pegar, você pode gostar de ter a
referência deles, né, a [música]
espaçamentos, talvez a como é que eles
fazem aqui a os menus e tal. E depois
você vai naturalmente editando, né?
Oh. [música]
>> [música]
[música]